but as no consciousness involved in this
there's no planning it's no you know
there's nothing like that it's just
writing
but the intuition is is is almost always
exactly right it's the right thing to do
and it's like if if there is a problem
in the novel
two o'clock in the in the afternoon I
know if I just go to sleep and get up in
the morning it's solved you know and
it's very
it's very interesting
and my I think my favorite quote about
writing an art is is by Laurence Darrell
and is says
writing a novelist to set yourself a
goal and then you go there in your sleep
and I think it's I think it's basically
it's like that
I think it's very hard to plan
a novel yeah
it's funny you say that because I have
found myself when I'm describing a
passage in the book to someone I often
say oh and then in the dream I mean
sorry I mean in the book yeah there is
something very dreamlike and in fact
that that passage you described with
your father when he suddenly changed
he's he's left your mother and you say
that he's even started to dress in a
more feminine way as if he's discovering
his freedom and in a sense that
discovery of Freedom goes into his
drinking as well uh which is a phase
that you have yourself when you're 19
later on
um
and
that whole that whole section feels like
a dream as well you're walking into the
forest and then suddenly your father is
sitting there and this man who we've
become very used to being authoritarian
brutal is something crying tears
remembering a girl who died when he was
a teenager yeah
but so
you're writing these books
this is just for yourself and I think
you even said before you said I just
wanted to get this stuff out of my
system so that I could go and write a
great novel yeah you know knowing that
actually that's what was happening in
front of you
what changed what was the moment when
you suddenly started realizing actually
this really dramatic truth that I'm
writing about my father's death
and your grandmother being there and
your experience your own family your
uncle is in the book your brother is in
the book your mother is in the book
when does this moment start happening
that you start thinking actually I'm
going to publish these things
what changed there
um no I was writing it
asset should be published you know I
thought we published but it wasn't up to
me it was up to my
to my editor but my change in in
realizing what it was was
um
for publishing I gave it to a friend of
mine
and there was and when I talked about
the novel he said it was I talked about
one one part of the novel
like he was kind of almost scared about
it and that's the scene in um
my father is is dead
the day before
and my grandmother has gone all day and
asked us if you don't drink do you you
know
and we I said no no no no because I'm
I'm sure she wants to assure her that we
don't drink as my father did but then in
the end we realized that she want to
drink and then the day after my father
died we sit in the kitchen and we we
drink and we get drunk and we get happy
you know and it was such a
terrible complex situation because it
was so good but it was so terrible at
the same time and when he reacted that
way on that then I understand but he was
kind of it was like he um yeah then I
thought this is this is working in a way
I don't know
then of course all the anger from all
the other people came well I was going
to say because then before you published
it you showed it to your family members
and your father's family members but
they wanted to stop it being published
yet I did yeah absolutely and there was
a very dramatic situation for a month
and I tried to stop it and
and they were you know the worst thing I
the one thing I can't deal with in my
life is anger is these people racing the
voice I get I get so scared it's because
my father I think he was he was doing
that
and then it's my father's brother you
know coming with this almost biblical
rage against me and and you had had done
something wrong it is immoral you know I
have
conflicted pain on them
and I don't have to publish I mean the
book isn't printed I could I could stop
it and that was that was such a it was
hell for me
uh and also very morally difficult
because
um they were saying you know
that
how can you
say that your book is more important
than our life you know
and I can't say that but what I it
changed for me when I realized that who
are you to say that you can't write
about your father you know
but it has many aspects this conflict
because they they said that this didn't
really happen your father didn't die of
alcoholism he had a heart attack and
there was no drinking there was no
bottles uh this was this just didn't
happen it's all a lie you know
and when you write you use your memory
and you use your imagination and those
things are very you know connected
and I am I have often used my father's
not often but occasionally used my
father's destiny
to become interesting myself you know I
can use it like you know
and then like a good story then I
started to doubt did it really happen
you know did this really happen and I
called my brother and and he said but he
was in shock he doesn't know the details
he didn't he said but then there was no
Witnesses and was this was this just a
novel you know
and had I just been exaggerating and
almost
so that was
it was it was so terrible
to to be in that situation where I also
had to decide to to publish it
um and then we published I decided to do
it
and then something interesting happening
because it was someone writing a letter
to me and and that person said I was
reading this book you know about the
father's death
and I remember the house
and I remember I was in that house you
know and she wrote man that was one of
the medical person who was bringing my
dead father out
and she told me how it was she told me
exactly what was going on and and that
was a terrible letter to get to because
it actually was worse than
than um than I know it was it was worse
than what you saw when you arrived in
the house yeah it was I mean there were
bottles Everywhere by the time yeah and
it was worse because and that's very
painful uh but that was because he had
been lying dead longer than we knew so
he has been dead and my grandmother has
been there and she was too confused to
call anyone out
this is an awful and and I feel still
feel very guilty for just going there
you know because it's so this is people
this is my family this is you know yeah
um but then again it's the truth and
it's my father and it is
it's these things happens I don't think
it's dangerous I don't think it's
anything wrong
but by telling this you know I really
don't
um but these things are are very
difficult of course
is that what I mean because exactly I
know I know that you feel terrible guilt
about having published it and and as you
say the word you use is immoral as if
it's a sinful thing to have done this
but something stronger was there yeah
but it is you know I've been raised in
this this is also a kind of a literature
for me is
Freedom it is a liberating force in my
life and and it is as a reader but also
as a writer
so this book in many levels is a way of
getting you know free literary Freedom
that's getting rid of the form you know
yeah and and it's
but when I'm talking about the book in
these terms it sounds like this really
is personal you know it's it is really
isn't novels it's kind of a project for
myself to to to get a better life
that when you're a writer you write
what's there for you and this was this
was what I had you know
I think yeah